all right it's from the New York Post
former president Barack Obama wrote of
his own androgynous mind and making love
to men daily but in the imagination
according to the redacted portion of a
now notorious 1982 letter obtained by
the post
so
we talked last week about this letter
where Biden or rather Obama
mentioned his homosexual fantasies but
at that point that part of the letter
had been redacted so we didn't know what
it actually said and now we know what's
in the actual letter
the more than 40 year old letter to an
ex-girlfriend recently resurfaced after
Obama biographer David Garrow gave a
long and winding interview on the
one-time commander-in-chief in regard to
homosexuality
um quote this is a quote now in regard
to homosexuality
I must say that I believe this is an
attempt to remove oneself from the
present to refusal perhaps to perpetuate
the endless farce of Earthly life you
see I make love to men daily but in the
imagination
is what Obama wrote to Alex McNair in
November of 1982.
my mind is androgynous to a great extent
and I hope to make it more so until I
can think in terms of people not women
as opposed to men
but in returning to the body I see that
I have been made a man and physically in
life I choose to accept that contingency
McNair who dated Obama during his years
at Occidental College in Los Angeles
later redacted the salacious paragraphs
which the Pulitzer prize-winning
historian Garrow hunted down and
included in his book Rising Star the
letter is currently owned by Emory
University which doesn't permit it to be
photographed or removed instead garo's
friend Harvey Claire transcribed the
paragraphs by hand and sent them to the
author
Okay so
I think they're
maybe two takeaways here there are no
surprises nothing is surprising about
this at all but there are two takeaways
and
the first before we get to homosexuality
stuff the first is is that Obama has
been a pompous tool his entire life
again not a surprise but that's a
takeaway
my mind is androgynous for I yearn to be
released from the confines of this
binary serfdom of constructed realities
like this is
this is Amanda Gorman tier faux
profundity is is what it is like this
dude actually wrote the phrase
unironically
quote perpetuate the endless farce of
Earthly life he actually wrote that
phrase
um
and ironically
it is in a certain way it's like it's
this is a certain way that the
straightest thing he's ever done also
because this is It's Like A desperate
attempt to oppress this girl it's how
desperate he is that he's writing stuff
like this
this will impress her now she really
think I'm smart
um
but the straightest thing is also
extremely gay because we also know that
he uh that he confessed to his gay
fantasies I just hope that the girl
wrote him back and was like dear Barry
you are at least 70 IQ points dumber
than you think you are
but I think nobody ever told him that
his entire life which is which explains
everything that happened after if you
want some positive news in the culture
War well since Roe v Wade was overturned
the left has lost their mind making
abortion their official Sacrament the
pro-life efforts which are more
important now than ever are booming you
heard that right despite the narrative
pro-lifers didn't go away they increased
in number it's one of the largest
pro-life organizations in the world no
one's in a better position than 40 Days
for life to end abortion in each state
in a post-rural America 40 Days for life
is changing hearts and Minds in the most
blue pro-abortion States they've had a
record number of locations since Roe was
overturned and they grew in both
volunteers and locations with about a
million Volunteers in 1500 cities they
held they hold peaceful vigils outside
abortion facilities you can help them
fight the ongoing legal Battles by
protecting free speech for the
volunteers by getting a tax deductible
gift of any amount at 40daysforlife.com
that's 40daysforlife.com
uh but then again we get to the the
second big takeaway which is the gay
fantasy
um
and this is now it's confirmed
you know
it's confirmed at the very least that
this guy was having homosexual fantasies
in his early 20s
um if you want to theorize that uh well
it doesn't mean that he ever acted on
them or it was actually that he ever was
an act of homosexual
now that's one Theory I don't find it
terribly plausible
but this is another one of those things
that
I mean for years for years and years
you had
many people on the right
talking about this
you know let's say predicting this about
Obama
and we were told it's all it's just
rumors that's nothing it's ridiculous
conspiracy theory conspiracy mongering
and even though it's not a conspiracy at
all well in a certain way it is so like
to to there's actual conspiracy theory
conspiracy here to cover up this this
was written this is document and it's
almost sexual advantages fantasies were
documented and then they were redacted
by this University
so there is an actual conspiracy of
cover-up here
and uh for so long they were they were
it was dismissed as a as nothing before
the conspiracy theory so really
we have to chalk this up as yet another
con quote-unquote conspiracy theory that
has been confirmed
as they almost always are and this is
another one hey YouTube thanks for
listening to the show if you'd like
access to my full show with no ads you
should go to dailywire.com and use promo
code Walsh to get two months free on all
annual plans see you there